all
right okay so uh I been
um I think what you what what you're
doing is very very
common um it's so common I've never seen
my way actually
done um so we have to start over like on
what we think is happening okay
um in
tenin this is going to represent UK's
spine our head's at the top here it
comes forward and usually what people
think
is that it's going to go like this in
some way so sometimes you have some ukas
that will slide
under okay and then sometimes you have
ukas like if this had a hinge here and
and this top part goes like this they
Bend backwards okay at at the back and
then they go B they go backwards into
the back breakfall but either way uh if
we just look at the head
area uh it's going that way which in our
Dojo is east and then the head is
brought West okay and either way whether
the feet keep going or whether it bends
here
and then they do the step back back
break fall or some do a a a rear
somersault or a rear uh uh forward roll
or sorry rear roll whatever none of that
stuff is what we want to do because
they're coming from west to east and we
pushing that head back from east to west
so that's a y y Clash okay we don't want
to do that so if uh this is where the
heaven arm would be what we want to do
instead is we know for the head to
go
from back to West then it has to be
brought on that Circle the Kay Circle so
that its forward inertia is maintained
you you have to do that in every
technique any technique where there's a
back break fall there's this little
yield here um I've come to this is a y
yield but I've come to actually uh uh
sometimes referred to it as o sense's y
yield because this is what he does all
the time okay and none of none of the
people do it that came after him okay
but the head comes forward it's going to
keep going with this forward inertia on
this Loop sometimes I refer to it as
it's like kotes on the head like a lot
of people will do it on kesi but they
don't do it on any of the other throws
teni nugget Ed nugget C hole but it's
the same you do it the same way so think
of it that way the head is going to go
forward on this Loop like this
okay um and then what happens is uh now
I'm not fighting it cuz now it's inertia
is
going uh West even though know the
body's coming east okay and now what I
have to do is help make the feet light
okay and the way you do that is you now
bring the head this
way okay your hip's going to go in
here crap all right you're going to go
this way you make that little Loop and
now you come this
way then your hip goes in here
and this part starts to now fol them
around this way and as the feet are
lifting the head is getting light so the
head we know is going down but I'm not
actually throwing it down it's more I
pick the feet up and I help pick the
feet up by moving the head this way and
then eventually that head Falls over on
this side okay so let's film it from
over
here see you can see more of the angles
the head is going forward it's going to
do that
kotes on the head now the forward
inertia is going rearward okay then I
got to get weight off the feet and so I
bring the head this way with my hip over
here the head goes this way the feet go
that way and the feet start to lower the
head and the guy falls down okay one
more time this way on the head then back
this way Hip is over here it'll lighten
the feet the feet will come around as I
keep guiding the head around my body and
the guy falls down
okay not doing
this like that
okay so let's look at some of the more
common ways that
people um mistakenly end up Yong Yong
clashing that means that they're coming
this way and you just took energy uh in
100 uh 180° opposition to them okay so
we'll do that
now okay uh let's go over
here so probably the most common way is
we'll just look at the earthand is the
earth hand the person's coming in and
then we pull it this way
okay so this hand looks like
this
okay uh a lot of people are thinking
that you're going to shove that down
like that and then you have now shaku
and then you enter into
it but what happens is is when you when
you pull this thing around like that you
can see the pull I'm doing on his
shoulder so I'm just demonstrated it
from this angle
okay
okay and so now that
shoulder is coming back which means that
other shoulder is coming forward and you
can see how it sets them up for that
turn that you have uh that problem with
okay which means if he wants to he could
take that turn
you
see and that's that's the problem so I'm
contesting on the grib and now I made it
possible for the UK who wants to turn to
turn
okay it goes this
way and it doesn't matter if I
enter and do it every time okay so what
we want to do on this hand is not go
this
way it's going to help with that pattern
so I showed the pattern on this side so
we'll do it on this side okay he's going
to go
in and then around me this way
okay so if we look at certain things
one when I do this
hand and I go here like that we want to
look at where his foot is to my hip it's
way over
there and we want to bring him more in
past my hip and that's where that hand
drops I want him past my
head and that's where this leg comes in
now this now brings his head this
way this way not this
way let him pass you and then you enter
when you cut this arm down don't pull it
you're just guiding it it's very light
here that's how you know when to drop it
when you don't feel his energy on it
anymore boom that's when it drops and
that's when your body comes
in this
way drops in
this foot is your my foot so you decide
where it goes to allow all that to
happen you kind go
forward but he has to pass you before
the hand drops you can go back he has to
pass you before the hand drops okay
let's just work on the Earth handam
okay so this
is more of my intermediate student and
she has that 180 degree oppositional
mindset you can
see where things
are okay it's very very
common try it again
she's just running at him
okay so uh pay attention to the grid we
have here so
north south camera West East okay and so
as I'm doing this I'm not going to go
here and
West you're already starting that
Circle so he's not going east anymore
okay and so and when I
I'm more uring North if you pay
attention so I'm not going
here
here do it again this is
oppositional I'm going to change his
direction right away and now we're
Circle
here
oppositional everyone thinks that's
going to work
okay instead
Circle W this
way Circle
this
this if you watch my feet the deeper he
gets my uh EDI foot probably moves away
from
the direction he came from so right now
it's on this
[Music]
line he's going in
yeah I'm going that way okay so one more
time right
here going this
way
circle circle
[Music]
line start this
rotating okay other thing that this does
for you versus this is it allows his
Center to kind of stay there and that's
what allows him to turn on
it this is going to bring his Center up
and this now has some resistance to the
turn cuz his inertia is going this way
he's hard to turn there he needs to keep
his Center over his foot now he can
pouette on that
foot it's hard to pouette like
this it's a lot harder
okay so combine those get the center up
a lot of times your UK have their butt
back
you see you're making their butt go back
as you're doing this and they end up
grouo marks walking around you and when
you take their weight off that's when
they can turn on you so how that Center
up in
circle okay back on the circle try it
now we'll we'll look at the at the um
Heaven hand okay so I'm not just getting
out of the way
again I'm not doing this so my my hand
if you watch the heaven hand a lot of
people the second mistake that people do
is the heaven hand is going forward
forward cuz they're going to throw
[Music]
that anytime my hand is going
forward and I'm oppositional to him
forward I don't want that just like this
hand is going this way this hand is
going this way too it's coming back
towards me back towards me
okay so a lot of times just like on the
earth hand uh people bring it only a
little bit where his foot's not over
here and then they start bringing it
back here the same thing you get sub
opening but now it's going it's going
that way and it stops a person stops a
person and when it stops a person it
gives him a choice to turn on it and you
can do the forward
roll what we're trying to do is stop him
from being able to turn by preoccupying
his center with the forward
inertia it's hard to turn when your
Center is being pulled that way okay
that's that's our our counter to the
turn all right so we work on this
hand and it's the inward spiral yes but
it wants to control the
elbow and this becomes as if I'm holding
here and I pull this forward
here and I'm pulling it forward so he
keeps going
forward when you combine this elbow like
that and they're both pulling it's not
possible to turn cuz there's pulling
here try to turn it's pulling him that
way so we're going to just look at this
hand and this hand goes here and it
moves him back forward
and back this way that's what I mean
it's making him go
forward and it breaks him to here I
don't bring this to here I bring his
head to here to me
don't go to him cuz then the hand has to
go forward so let's say you're here and
you're like I can't go anymore it goes
up and that brings him
in it's not I don't want you to do it
with your turn with your turn I don't I
don't really change the relationship
we're just oriented differently
they are here like I can't get anymore
that's where you start going up it
brings him
in okay try that part of the heaven hat
okay all right so I combined the two
hands I combine the
footwork and with those that's my Yin
yield okay so I'm going to show
it I'm going to bring him to the heaven
hand here okay once he's there to go
forward is now
to contest him and when you go forward
that's where he can
turn so what I'm going to do instead is
move out this way and that's that's the
K on the head so I was showing it on the
sword on this side so I'll show it here
I bring him into the hand once he's
touching this hand is go like
this that's what moves him this
way and that's what I'm calling o
y this way
so if you pay
attention is if he was to pette on this
foot he has to leave it in place you
see but when you do this yield watch
that foot
cat if he tries to turn on it it's
getting
moved the throw I I haven't thrown yet
but there's already enough
reconciled West East direction that he's
already folling that way okay without me
moving my hands from where he came
from okay try that part okay a second
detail on this on the heaven hand okay
for him to
turn he can't have his head going the
other way so here would be a a a linear
energy against his chin and he's going
to turn this way the head the head is
now acting against that okay so when
he's in the heaven hand and he's she
like that and you can't you're throwing
him basically into the hand so he's
pressing into the hand okay it's not
it's not easy to turn your head that way
because even though I'm bringing his
head this way if you don't mind
his linear inertia is pushing him into
my hand you see and as I move this way
it's difficult for him to turn his chin
in the direction do do you understand
that
whereas if I don't have him cuz I'm
pushing my head this way his forward
inertia he's going to yield to it by
turning and he's in the pivot okay so
I'm going to smash him into my arm arms
boom and it makes it hard for him to
turn the chin and I don't need him to
not turn the chin ever I just need him
not to turn the chin long enough for me
to enter
okay when I
enter and I have him
here I don't now try to throw his
head okay I have them like this I so go
back where I show you where I'm at
brething elbows bringing it in on the
heaven hand uh Earth hands bringing his
Center forward I make him make contact
there i y yield here okay and now to
throw my
arm is to still contast what I'm going
to do
instead is as the weight is not on his
legs now and the inertia was coming
through on his Center
imagine here's his head I hold his head
still camera over here you're going to
grab his Center this camera over here
this is what I'm working with this makes
his feet light and I can now make his
head light okay so when you gets to
where I want here this is where I'm
coming in and hitting this
base as the base gets displaced his head
gets lighter and all I'm doing is
guiding it around me I'm not throwing
them down so I don't ever have to make
my arm go against that energy coming
west to east just around
sh
okay so uh what I'm doing here is that
body lock concept we have a video on the
body lock Maybe more than one but it's
the only way I throw I only throw with
the body lock especially on the back
breakfall um as opposed to requiring a
hinge in the middle of his body like the
bonai does or uh the Federation at large
where they sit their butt down you see
that it has that hinge in the body still
is just going the other way than bonai
and uh none of that happens martially uh
people that are aggressing uh they will
lock their own body up uh and then with
inertia too the inertia acting on him
will lock the body up so all I have here
at this point with all that stuff I've
done with the tabaki the Ashi saaki the
yin yield the IE adhesion Etc is to
create a kind of rigidity on his body
that's what you want okay um you don't
want you don't want this okay and what
what I'm doing here is and I'll just go
see the video on the body lock okay but
there is the ademi angle where I can be
on the front top part of it like the
bulen and the bottom part back of it and
that's what you're throwing when you do
these techniques it's kind of I'm gaming
it here but instead of bending them
backwards and then he goes
you're kind of just hitting
here you want it to lock but your body
has to be in a certain place for that
okay and that I found even my dis you
don't quite get it as you go down in the
rank there's a place what they usually
Miss is the coordination between the
upper part and the bottom part uh and
then secondarily where where does this
EDI go they missed that part they're
doing some other stuff over here over
this way like a trip let me move your
leg please like this and that's not it
you're coming in one is here this is
exaggeration just so you can see the
physics involved okay cuz remember in
the technique we're going to figure a it
on the vertical plane here I'm not doing
that this has to coordinate with this
EDI
displacement so that his body and lock
okay that's the body lock and that's in
the technique that also makes it very
very difficult to turn okay try it